[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero Sale ya está con nosotros en
el estudio Marc llegamos al viernes y
vamos a dedicar hoy el espacio de salud
para hablar de los anticonceptivos en el
continente americano desde la pandemia
del 19 ha habido una falta de insumos
que por supuesto también hemos hablado
aquí en nuestro espacio de salud de
directoamérica cómo estás Raúl así hemos
decidido traer a colación este tema
porque la semana pasada fue la semana de
la prevención del embarazo adolescente
en la región estuvimos hablando también
de la despenalización del aborto toda
esta semana Entonces vamos a traer la
última pieza de este rompecabezas
alrededor de la salud sexual que es los
anticonceptivos no que son claves para
dar pues agencia a las mujeres para
decidir si quieren o no tener hijos como
cuando De qué forma Y para evitar
maternidades pues no deseadas que tienen
un gran impacto en la salud traemos aquí
Unas cifras publicadas por la
organización Panamericana de la salud
que demuestran precisamente la
importancia que tienen esos
anticonceptivos Y es que entre 2020 y
2021 hubo una escasez de anticonceptivos
en el Continente principalmente dada por
la pandemia la interrupción de servicios
de salud entre el 14 y el 17 por ciento
esto tiene consecuencias muy reales muy
vividas en las vidas de las mujeres y de
personas que pueden algestar vimos que
esto pues tuvo como consecuencia casi
dos millones de embarazos no
planificados Además de varias muertes
por ejemplo muertes maternas
2.939.000 muertes infantiles Por qué
Pues porque los embarazos no deseados
pueden empujar por ejemplo a las mujeres
a tener abortos inseguros que sabemos
que pues pueden suponer un riesgo para
esa salud también embarazos No deseados
pues pueden suceder en personas que no
quieran quedarse embarazadas
precisamente porque no tienen los
recursos sociales para cuidar hacer
frente Pues a un niño a un nuevo nacido
entonces pues bueno sabemos eso que este
acceso anticonceptivo es interrumpido
por la pandemia y también actualmente
sigue interrumpido de hecho algún juego
o dificultado al menos digamos Pues por
los problemas en la cadena de
suministros en los precios de energía
pues tienen unas consecuencias muy
reales en la vida de las mujeres de la
región hablemos de los varios métodos
anticonceptivos que existen en la
actualidad Cuáles son ellos más sí
hagamos este repaso por suerte tenemos
una amplia variedad lo único que falta
es que realmente sean accesibles a todo
el mundo como estábamos viendo no los
primeros son los métodos Barrera el
preservativo puede ser el preservativo
masculino observativo femenino también
existe es importante decirlo también y
pues que sabemos que sirven para evitar
el embarazo y también pues las
enfermedades de transmisión sexuales que
digamos es el único método de todos
estos que previenen los contagios
qué tenemos más los métodos hormonales
por ejemplo los de acción corta como las
píldoras el anillo vaginal también los
parches que básicamente tienen el mismo
funcionamiento con distintas vías de
aplicación Y es pues a proporcionar
hormonas pueden ser hormonas combinadas
o simples solo progesterona que hacen
que el óvulo no se produzca interrumpen
digamos afectan el ciclo menstrual y el
ciclo hormonal de la mujer para evitar
que el óvulo se produzca y así el
embarazo también Existen los de larga
duración por ejemplo el Diu o el
implante pues por ejemplo muchas veces
en el brazo sin plátano que evitan el
embarazo durante años y no se tienen que
estar tomando mensualmente ni
diariamente ni se van al mente y
finalmente hay métodos que no es que no
son reversibles no los la vasectomía
para los hombres la ligadura de trompas
para las mujeres y finalmente mencionar
Pues que hay gente que decide no usar
esos métodos sino hacer un trabajo como
de conocer el propio ciclo y ver en qué
momentos es menos fértil o no es una
decisión totalmente respetable mientras
se sepa que nunca va a ser efectiva al
100% porque la mujer puede quedar o la
mejor en la personas con útero pueden
quedar embarazadas en cualquier momento
de su ciclo menstrual Así es mar Pero
alrededor de los anticonceptivos
hormonales existen por supuesto muchos
mitos y mucha desconfianza vamos a ver
con la verdad y la mentira Cuáles de
estos mitos son reales y cuáles no si
vamos a hablar de esto Vamos a ponerle
cifras y también a entender sus razones
no porque es indiscutible que hay
efectos secundarios en la toma de este
medicamento como ha ido mucho Sobre todo
por ejemplo en en los tratamientos
hormonales y cada persona tiene que
decidir si los riesgos superan los
beneficios No lo que pasa es que muchas
veces se han desestimado estos efectos
secundarios que reportan las mujeres que
toman los anticonceptivos como suele
pasar todo el tiempo con muchísimas
dolencias o problemas o síntomas que
dicen las mujeres lo vimos también con
las vacunas del 19 no se suelen
desestimar también se recetan
anticonceptivos para problemas que a
veces no tienen que ver con querer
quedarse embarazada o no sino por
ejemplo para sí o para evitar dolores
menstruales que deberían investigarse o
tratarse quizás de otras formas Y eso ha
generado que exista esa desconfianza
para los usos anticonceptivos hormonales
que pueden llegar realmente a ser muy
lógicos no también hay realmente como
decíamos de algunos cambios puede
cambiar por ejemplo el acné o la
producción de pelo también acumulación
de líquido sobre todo en los primeros
meses que puede dar este sensación de
aumento de peso pero yo quería hablar de
dos mitos particularmente que son de
algo más gravedad uno es la fertilidad
gente que dice que tomar anticonceptivos
afecta la fertilidad a largo plazo no en
general Y la verdad es que no es decir
obviamente una persona no será fértil
Mientras esté tomando los tratamientos
pero una vez deje de tomar tratamientos
anticonceptivos volverá a ser fértil sin
ningún lugar a dudas quizás va a tomar
un par de meses del cuerpo bacterias así
bueno desintoxicación no sería una buena
palabra porque parece que entonces el
anticonceptivo sea tóxico pero como para
eliminar Digamos como de que el cuerpo
vuelva a acostumbrarse a su propio ciclo
hormonal y menstrual eso es cierto pero
eso es todo eso no quiere decir que las
personas te vayan a ser pues infértiles
o tengan menos capacidad de quedarse
embarazadas después y el último es el
tema del cáncer no con las píldoras
anticonceptivas ha dicho que provocan o
pueden dar más riesgo de cáncer vamos a
revisar cifras recopiladas por múltiples
estudios del Instituto Nacional del
cáncer y vemos Que si hay un leve
aumento de riesgo de cáncer de seno y de
cáncer de cuello uterino Pero en cambio
parece reducirse en otros tipos de
cáncer por ejemplo el cáncer de colon el
cáncer de ovario sin embargo Por qué es
tan importante decir que estas cifras
expresan una correlación no una calidad
no expresan que la píldora
anticonceptiva cause cáncer eso todavía
no se conoce y Un ejemplo muy claro es
el cáncer de cérvix del cáncer de cuello
uterino no vemos ese aumento de riesgo
podría ser perfectamente porque las
mujeres una vez están tomando pues
anticonceptivos hormonales dejan de usar
preservativo entonces pueden tener más
riesgo de contagiarse del virus del
papiloma humano que es el que provoca el
cáncer entonces pues estamos tenemos que
estar muy alerta a la hora de manejar
estas